paul thompson vice présidente de la
section parisienne du parti conservateur
britannique en france
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir en direct sur rt france un nouveau
traité avec le royaume-uni est-il
envisageable dans ce contexte de vives
tensions entre londres et paris
c'est toujours envisageable et je pense
que il y avait eu connaissance des deux
côtés qu'il y a un problème concret
majeur
sur lequel il
qu'ils ou elles il faut améliorer des
choses donc ça ne l'idée n'a rien de
nouveau
le ministre français de l'intérieur a
demandé à londres d'accepter plus de
demandes d'asile mais aussi de mieux
faciliter l'immigration légale au
royaume-uni que lui répondre
je pense que cette cette demande tout
peu hors sujet parce que
chaque pays
définissent sa propre politique
d'immigration de la france ne voudrais
pas que sa politique soit indéfinie par
des états unis par le japon ni par
nombre et
et il est temps que je pense que
7,7 or ce genre ce qui est
important c'est de coopérer pour
réprimer une
immigration illégale c'est ça monsieur
alors pour paris a pas de remise en
cause des accords du touquet sur la
frontière franco britannique cet
arrangement qui a été signée en 2003 et
qui conduit les policiers français à
contrôler les migrants avant leur
traversée de la manche en échange d'une
compensation financière pour la france
est ce qu'il ne faut pas le renégocier
de nombreux candidats à la
présidentielle en france en tout cas le
trouva obsolète
je pense que il pourrait y avoir des
améliorations nous je pense qu'il
conviendrait de les garder c'est
de garder la base à savoir le contrôle
côté français med
d'améliorer les modalités de
fonctionnement
vous avez dans le reportage est évoqué
deux éléments concrets de doublement des
effectifs la la mise en place de mise en
service de deux hélicoptères pour
effectuer des patrouilles il ya ce sont
des éléments très positifs à d'autres
idées seraient des patrouille conjointe
avec avec des éléments à de la goutte
d'or frontières du royaume uni
cette idée a été évoquée
côté londres et je ne sais plus quelle a
été la réponse de 2,2 paris l'idée
d'une renvoi de droit munis de la france
de personnes qui il également on veut
réussi le passage
ferait sens
monaco s'est émue du fait que cette idée
a été a été très publiquement parce que
boston a fait publier une lettre qui lui
avait envoyée peut-être que ce produit
procédé de la publication des lettres
étaient malvenus c'est possible mais
l'idée sur le fond à
n'est pas mauvaise du tout il faut
regarder ce qui se passait quand une
accord entre la turquie et l'union
européenne a été conclu en 2000 2015
cela a été une grande efficacité pour
réduire presque à néant les flux
provenant de la turquie vers vers la
grèce am parce que ainsi les des
candidats au passage staff que même
s'ils réussissent le passage du vent est
renvoyée aussitôt leur motivation pour
faire le passage
est réduit très simplement donc en fait
c'est une idée qui je pense mériterait
d'être
examinées peut-être même si elle aura
peut-être dû être traité avec plus de
discrétion des britanniques elle vous
évoquez cette lettre dans laquelle boris
johnson a donc demandé à paris à jo le
site de reprendre les migrants
arrivons au royaume uni depuis la france
c'est ce sont ces déclarations qui ont
conduit la france à des invités les
britanniques de cette réunion qui s'est
tenue dimanche à calais en présence de
ministres et officiels allemands
hollandais belges et français vous
évoquez tout à l'heure cette nécessaire
coopération sur ce dossier ce qu'il y a
réelle volonté de la part de boris
johnson de coopérer avec paris c'est
parce qu'il ressentit à côté côté
français
oui je suis sûr que lire une réelle
volonté de coopération
et je pense côté français aussi ce thème
le cas donc il faut espérer
que on dépasse les
[Musique]
l'aller les lames il ya des guerres des
démos des désastres qui n'a rien de de
bons jeux de reins
les gouvernements sont des acteurs
politiques ils ont une opinion publique
à gérer si je puis dire dans leurs pays
respectifs qui est il y à une élection
qui a vu en france l'année prochaine
donc toutes ces acteurs politiques entre
contres en ligne du compte et c'est
inévitable
néanmoins il faudrait un sursaut pour
passer à un
travail constructif sur le fond je suis
sûr que les responsables des deux côtés
ça très bien que c'est nécessaire
c'est un problème qu'il commet qui
concerne les deux pays
grandement dans les deux cas je dirais
donc tant qu'homme
donc à son ou aux
questions pratiques et d'état sonder les
postures les 7,7 des invitations noël un
patel à mon humble avis n'était pas une
bonne une bonne décision mr c'était une
faute et gestes
[Musique]
passagers je pense que il faut regarder
le côté positif de cette initiative
d'aujourd'hui de monsieur castex est il
faut s'en féliciter
considérer que c'est un signal à on
positive un peu le côté britannique
devrait saisir pour aller de l'avant
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation paul thompson vice président
de la section parisienne du parti
conservateur britannique en france